attention james bond
as tu n'étais pas trop ça on accorde son
pardon
est ce que tu es blessé mais je vais te
répondre que cordialement
bien évidemment quand fêter ce truc bon
bah c'est tom roulera avec une bande
collante sur sa caisse au nom galbées si
au nom fait deux élèves watts mais tu me
tires tu m'agresses pourquoi bah oui
neubourg fallait pas qu'on ait une
salopette la moindre des choses c'est de
ne pas énerver les autres contrats je
m'enfuis à l'aide de mon avion agricole
et au pardon monsieur l'agent envole-toi
au cactus avec toi je m'en fous lepoutre
temps non on ne m'aurait jamais
peut-être dans deux minutes
excusez-moi revois tes cours de kung fu
toi aussi tu cherches le tram hop je
suis caché je suis caché regardez je
suis extrêmement bien caché allez je
vais décoller je venais collet on y
croit houle
je ne savais pas impossible le train
vite le train oui oh oui oh c'est
magnifique dégagé attention une menace
potentielle a été détectée 20 mai c'est
à lyon mais on dirait qu'à tout moment
il peut exposer quoi et voici la vie
j'ai un parachute à hasnon j'avais un
parachute pourtant tétouan à c'est comme
ça qu'est la belgique hold up à mettet
beaux mecs en bardeaux on a envie de
faut que je cache ce corps et hop voilà
j'ai tué personne le correctif à la
police arrive vite cachot dans les
fougères
tu as tu fait peur à tout le monde juste
en sautant quoi ça suffit steve pana
c'est pas par là laissez-moi allé me
cacher et que c'est en cachette vous
n'aurez jamais attendons la fin de ses
surprises ou quoi vous m'avez vu ou pas
ça près mais qu'est ce qui me prend
qu'est ce qu'il fait là est ce qu est ce
qui a fait en tout air comme ça va vite
et si c'est bon parra a alors soit j'ai
un groupe de musique dans le dos soit
c'est une balle à noël m'a tuer
ah ouais
et personne n'aurait jamais retrouvé le
corps de très bons aulas j'ai encore
perdu 5000 $ pour le [ __ ] [ __ ]
attendait mais brest 29 millions ça va
bien la cua wicht a dit aram aussi
j'aime bien les dj's même les beach les
biches mais je comprends pas sûr c'est
qu'on était comme un bien en étant
saluée moi tu t'appelles asia
c'est ça que tu as dis ça me va j'aime
bien ce qui vous est ce que c'est toi
c'est que tu es très féminin steve o
c'était toi sur ton japon se trouve
estompe stich choisis tu souhaites
ressembler un très fort
courir au ralenti dans la rue en faisant
semblant d'être un pur boulot à ce qui
transpire parce qu'il est beau c'est
parti à [ __ ] je voulais tenter de
l'entrée par effraction de matha voiture
où je saute au salut voila je t'avais
dit je t'avais [ __ ] il a fait la libye
attendait mais attendez mais je lui
casser la vitre voilà ok donc les mecs
étaient deux et ils ont juste du trevor
ils ont eu peur je ne comprends pas
pourquoi
faut la suivre sans se faire repérer là
tu vas pas vu bon allez je te plaît à gt
est une idée ça te dirait toronto tu
appelle la police média coups de bottes
aux boîtes à la mort nul contre la
poubelle moi je vais chez coiffure en
avion attention coiffeur dans 3 e à du
macbook normale au oui monsieur sylvain
extrêmement bien ça s'est rasé de près
ou clochard voilà les pubs à faire des
trucs stylet tremor interdiction est bon
on parlera soit un coût cher donc tu me
rabats s'y attendait pas aux estives
c'est toi des versions plus de
maintenance et ça comme tu es vidéo non
c'est bon que m'aider moi étions en
battant aux enfers d'un homme écrasé le
me dépasse attendez ne vous inquiétez
pas l'ambulance arrive rassurez-vous à
l'ambulance et là y'a pas de raisons de
mourir un hot dog
la police ne recherche vous m'avez
jamais je peux trouver un véhicule super
rapide pour vous échapper
ouais j'avais j'ai trois gangsters on
veut jamais m'aurait jamais d'élus damon
qui veut du délit d'abord toi peut-être
en voici en voilà
non mais tu ce sujet que les poubelles
la tient de tours jaermann mois qu est
ce qu à la poubelle
qu'est ce cas
pardon traiteront de jouer je ne
contrôle plus rien en on aurait été
tellement beau la danse et dans cette
petite veste à sico starr ou là alors
attend attend déjà
déjà il est arrivé là mais la musique
nega c'est une paresse dans les oreilles
l'a fait allez maintenant je peux
remettre mon petit poney
hop en voici en voilà est ce que ça t'a
plu un temps a encore un petit résidus
sous la dent voilà en exclusivité voici
la voiture de trevor avant qu'ils
braquent des banques
s'il vous plaît ça fait dix ans que je
cherche l'amour de ma vie mais je les ai
vus au jeu les bus il est juste là dans
cette chambre il s'appelle et voilà les
gens c'est déjà la fin de cette petite
vidéo sur gta 5 j'espère que ça vous
aura plu on se retrouve très bientôt
dans nouvelle vidéo chat en pis et à
bientôt
tiens web simone il va laisser de marché
on le sait puisqu'on des photos comme
non non non salut la citrouille
le jeu vient de cracher très bientôt
au québec les voilà à quoi sert l'argent
fait soit pour acheter federico la
stupeur soutien écoute cadette longa